بالفعل وهو الاثقل على اسرائيل منذ السابع
من اكتوبر او بعد السابع من اكتوبر هذا
الهجوم الكبير المتحدث الرسمي باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول بان 21 جنديا وضابطا
قتلوا في وسط قطاع غزه يوم امس في المعارك
الدائره هناك وهو فصل في عمليه مقتلهم
هناك اشار
الى هدم منزلين على رؤوسهم بعد استهداف
قوه عسكريه كانت تتحصن بمنزلين في وسط
قطاع غزه باستهدافها كما يبدو بقاذفات
الار بي جي الموجهه وايضا استهداف دبابه
اسرائيليه كانت موجوده في مكان وجود
الجنود الاسرائيليين الجنود الاسرائيليين
في هذين الموقعين كانا يعملان على تفخيخ
هذان المزلان من اجل تدميرهما وا اعدوا
العده من اجل ذلك بانهم قاموا بوضع
المتفجرات في المنزلين ويبدو ان حجم
المتفجرات كان كبيرا للغايه وقاموا عمليا
بتفخيخ المتفجرات او بوضع المتفجرات في
هذين المنزلين قبل ان تقوم المقاومه
الفلسطينيه باطلاق صواريخ ار بي جي باتجاه
هذان المنزلين الذي تحصن بهما الجنود
وكانوا يعملون على تفريخه ما وهذا ربما ما
ادى الى حجم الانفجار الكبير الذي اودى
بهذا هذا العدد الكبير من الضباط والجنود
قتلى وبالاضافه الى استهداف دبابه
اسرائيليه كانت موجوده في موقع العمليه
هناك عمليه انتشال جثث الجنود
الاسرائيليين والضباط في هذه العمليه بحسب
المتحدث الرسمي العسكري في الجيش
الاسرائيلي استمر حتى الساعات الاخيره حتى
ساعات صباح هذا اليوم وهذا يفسر حجم
الدمار الكبير الذي احدثه هذا التفجير
وربما وجود جثث الجنود والضباط تحت كميه
كبيره من انقاد هذين المنزلين لذلك تاخر
ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي في الاعلان عن هذا
الخبر لعامه الاسرائيليين صباح هذا اليوم
عمليه انتشال الجثث استمرت لساعات طويله
طيله ليله امس والان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يقول بانه اخبر على الاقل 10 من عائلات
هؤلاء الجنود الضباط الذين قتلوا وانه سوف
يخبر ويعلن اسماء الجنود والضباط البقيه
خلال ساعات نهار هذا اليوم العمليه كما
قال الجيش الاسرائيلي وقعت في وسط قطاع
غزه في حوالي الساعه الرابعه عصرا حقيقه
نحن كنا موجودين في تلك الساعه في منطقه
غلاف غزه قباله المخيمات الوسطى اي لدى
حدوث هذه الانفجارات الضخمه ليله امس وكنا
قد نقلنا بالصوره المباشره الطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي الذي كان يحلق بكثافه في موقع
الانفجار واغار ايضا على عدد من المواقع
في تلك المنطقه ترافق ذلك ايضا مع قصف
مدفعي شديد في ساعه وقوع هذا الانفجار
وكنا اشرنا في وقته بان هذا ربما يشير الى
ان الجنود الاسرائيليين الذين يعملون في
الميدان قد وقعوا حقيقه في مازق ليتبين
ثقل هذه العمليه التي ادت الى مقتل 21
جنديا وضابطا اسرائيليا طبعا هذا يثير
كثير من التساؤلات في داخل اسرائيل حول
الجدوى من الزج بالجنود الاسرائيليين في
معركه كهذه او على الاقل في دفعهم للقيام
بمهام تفجير لمنازل ومواقع ومقار على
الارض في وقت يمكن للطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي ان يقوم بهذه المهمه والقاء
قنابله من من من السماء اتجاه هذه المواقع
المستهدفه لكن هنالك من يقول بان استهداف
هذه المواقع بالطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي
لن تكون مجديه فيما اذا كانت هذه المنازل
المستهدفه تشمل على فتوحات انفاق او على
مسارات انفاق هجوميه يريد الجيش
الاسرائيلي تدميرها لان تدمير المنازل من
الجوله يعني بالضروره ان المهمه قد
استكملت وان تدمير الانفاق او فتوحات
الانفاق في تلك المواقع قد يستكمل لذلك
الجيش الاسرائيلي
كما يقول البعض بحاجه احيانا الى الوصول
الى هذه المواقع وتفخيخ ووضع المتفجرات
فيها وتفجيرها عن بعد هذه هي المره
الثانيه التي يؤدي فيها تفجير منازل في
داخل قطاع غزه الى مقتل جنود اسرائيليين
حدث ذلك في مطلع العام الجديد في الايام
الاولى عندما قامت دبابه اسرائيليه
ب ضرب قذيفه مدفعيه باتجاه احد المواقع
لكن الشرار الذي انبعث من هذه القذيفه
ايضا ادى الى انفجار شاحنه كانت محمله
بالمتفجرات المعده لتفخيخ وتفجير بعض
المواقع في قطاع غزه وادى ذلك الى مقتل
عدد ايضا كبير من الجنود
الاسرائيليين كانت هنالك مشكله في كيفيه
تعاطي الجنود والضباط مع مساله الامن
والامان في قضيه التعاطي مع هذه الكميات
الكبيره والثقيله من المتفجرات التي
تستخدم في عمل تفجير المنازل وتفجير البنى
التحتيه
وتحديدا الانفاق الهجوميه ومسارات هذه
الانفاق التي تكون عاده متشعبه وطويله
ومساراتها طويله ومتشعبه وتحتاج ايضا الى
كميات كبيره من المتفجرات من اجل تدميرها
كليا اذا
اي فاتوره ثقيله يدفعها الجيش الاسرائيلي
من حيث عدد الجنود والضباط الاسرائيليين
الذين يقتلون في هذا اليوم الثقيل الذي
كما يوصف في وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
يوم حداد وطني 21 جنديا وضابطا اسرائيليا
يقتلون في عمليه واحده ونعيد فقط على
توصيف ما قاله المتحدث الرسمي باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي صباح هذا اليوم عندما قال بان
الجنود والضباط قتلوا عندما كانوا يقومون
بعمليه تفخيخ لمنزلين كانوا يستعدون
لتدميره ما يبدو ان المنزلين نحن نتحدث عن
شقق سكنيه او عمارتين على الاقل قاموا
بتفخيخ هذان المنزلين او هاتين العمارتين
ووضعوا فيها كميات كبيره من المتفجرات في
هذه اللحظات كانت كما يبدو قوه من
المقاومه الفلسطينيه تترصد لهذه المجموعه
من الجنود التي تحصنت داخل هذين المبنيين
وقامت باستهدافه ما بواسطه قذائف الار بي
جي الامر الذي ادى الى انهيار المبنيين
بشكل كامل ويبدو ان استهداف هذا هذين
المبنيين بقذائف الار بي جي ووجود هذه
الكميه الكبيره من المتفجرات ادى الى وقوع
انفجار ضخم و وكبير وادى الى انهيار
المبنيين بالكامل مما اودى بحياه 21 جنديا
وضابطا اسرائيليا في هذه العمليه وكما
اشرت بان الجيش الاسرائيلي احتاج الى
ساعات طويله طيله ليله امس من اجل رفع
الانقاد وانتشال جثث جنوده وضباطه الذين
قتلوا في هذه ال العمليه وهو اعلن حتى
الان اسماء عشره منهم وقال بانه سوف يعلن
في خلال الساعات القليله المقبله عن اسماء
الجنود والضباط البقيه الذين قتلوا في هذا
الحادث الذي يوصف في اسرائيل بانه الافض
والاثقال منذ السابع من اكتوبر الماضي